it comes down to that Murray rothbard
piece that it's do you hate the state
and yeah and that when you what people
don't like and I think a lot of them um
what gets a lot of them worked up is
that it's like when you see the
Libertarians kind of being like uh
taking this line that it's like you know
well they're just a bunch of jokers who
are really inefficient at how they
govern us and they've got these you know
they don't understand these unintended
consequences and these buffoons can't
get it right whereas like this other
Crow of Libertarians are like
these people are monsters these people
are monsters who are destroying people's
lives and they're enriching their
friends to do it and they know what
they're doing and they're doing it
anyway and there's this kind of like
reaction against the people who take
more of the the unintended Jokers I
honestly that both sides do in the
extremes do a bad analysis on this on on
looking at the motivations of why
government actors are doing what they're
doing I think think that saying that
they're all a bunch of goofballs uh
which isn't my argument by yeah is that
that's not the right way uh but also
saying that people in government are
particularly nefarious or evil um I mean
I I subscribe to just basic public
Choice Theory where they're driven by
the same incentives that the rest of us
are it's just it's self-interest and
self-image and it's you know fouchi has
bad incentives that's why he does what
he does it's not because he's an evil
person I think it's so I think it's well
fouchy is a we can talk about fouchy I I
do think that you know what Zach is
tapping into is true to how I look at it
too I think it's frequently a a mixture
of malice and incompetence and I think
sometimes it's it's sometimes a very
case-by casee thing where sometimes it's
more incompetence other times it's more
malice I would say with fouchi I would
probably uh you know say that that airs
more toward the side of malice but I
think that either explanation as almost
this it's like a reflexive tick where
it's like oh well State actors are
always malice and it's always you know
it's it's their evilness showing or the
other reflexive tick of well they're
never really corrupt um you know or evil
because they're always just dumb
incompetent buffoons like that shows
that you're not actually looking at the
facts of the case before you and to me
that indicates um you know a very
dogmatic way of looking at the world
that will lead you to bad conclusions so
I see it as frequently a mixture of the
so I certainly wouldn't say that there
it's like a 100% evil and that there is
no just kind of like buffoons there I
mean obviously there are tons of
buffoons in government but to your point
about like Hey look it's the same
incentives that drive all of us like
there there there's some truth to that
but that's almost like if there's like
you know uh some young man out there
who's like he's incentivized to want to
get laid so he like tries to charm a
girl and take her out on a date and then
there's another 25-year-old who rapes a
girl because you know what I mean like
they may have had the same incentive to
some degree but those are not like the
same type of people or that listen look
you can look at a lot of these examples
if you by the way if You' ever heard uh
Hillary Clinton on tape laughing about
getting a child rapist off when she knew
he was guilty like laughing about it
like she just thinks it's hilarious are
you on the Clinton kill list do you
think uh I I've done everything I can uh
to get there I don't I don't think I'm
close enough to him but uh but like the
like these people and a lot of these
people at the top level of government
are horrific evil people who will
knowingly you know like uh put in place
a policy where innocent people will die
they'll lie through their teeth to to
sell the policy their buddies will all
get rich off of it I mean like I don't
think it's like oh those are just like
kind of the same type of people as as a
guy who runs a bakery like they want
more power and he wants more power you
know like yeah they may all want things
but what some of these people are
willing to do to get it is like so like
crazy vicious and I do think that at the
at the top levels of our government
there it is permeated with violent
sociopaths who are very comfortable
doing very evil things and look I mean
even just like you look at the um like
when you step back and see some of this
and this is true in media too like you
know there's like a was that that woman
from uh ABC who was caught on the hot
mic talking about how she broke the
Jeffrey Epstein story but they they
pulled it from her right but one of the
crazy things about that hot mic is that
what she's upset about if you listen to
her is not what you think any normal
person should be upset about it's the
lack of clout it's that she didn't get
the story she's like and I have that's I
had the story that's journalist brain
right like that's a huge problem the
entire not maybe not the entire media
class but a significant a hefty portion
of the media class is obsessed with
their own bloated and frequently wrong
sense of moral superiority as well as
this just astonishing self-importance
that God made them journalists and
they're God's gift to man and it it
think about how evil that is how evil it
is that she didn't quit you didn't quit
and go break this story anyway you just
stayed there what cuz the paycheck's
good so you're telling me you had a
story about a child rapist ring with the
most powerful people in the country
implicated in this story and your bosses
for went now we're not gonna it'll mess
up our relationship with the royal
family that's what she says in the hot
mic and her response to that wasn't to
quit and just tell the story anyway like
that's that's insane and like so listen
am I judging her personally am I saying
like an evil I'm not saying she goes
home and kicks her dog in the face every
day but I'm saying what she is
participating in in her professional
life is something morally repugnant and
like that's how I feel about the highest
levels of government and media that
there there's just this Mass comp now
and by the way there's also I'm not
trying to get like all Alex Jones on you
here but like there is what do you think
about the atrazine in the water supply I
don't know any of that stuff but uh I
have read I think he was not completely
wrong about the frogs but whatever uh
that's a whole different thing listen
they look bohemian Grove is real okay
they do weird things there so I don't
know exactly what's going on with these
people and I don't like do
the and I don't like to jump down
conspiracies that I can't prove but it's
it is totally reasonable to look at like
the Epstein thing to look at Bohemian
Grove to look at these things and go
yeah there's something going on here
that's pretty weird okay but my my point
Dave is that if you are looking at it as
if this is because we're all ruled by
some satanic cabal and I that's not
exactly what you're saying but you're
kind of saying like Bohemian Grove they
get together it's wiing in that
direction it's it's the the problem with
that if it's wrong which I think that it
kind of is is that it supposes the
solution is to clear out this corrupt
class what am I wrong about in what I
just said like what's wrong about what I
just said what's what what I'm saying is
it's structural it's not it's primarily
structural and
where I think you're right is that
sometimes the Inc you know Hayek even
had an essay about this why the worst
get to the top and it's like because the
incentives of power do tend to draw
certain personalities so you might even
be right that there's a disproportionate
amount of sociopaths or Psychopaths uh
just like there are in Corporate America
why there's there's it's why there's so
many pedophiles who are are uh baseball
coaches or Little League coaches that's
why there there's so many you know like
uh abusive people who are cops because
these positions draw in those type of
people right I mean that's it's part of
the natural cycle of it but where I
think it gets um where the where the
populists um muddle this message is like
we have this uh you know shadowy class
of rulers that once we defeat them and
clear them out it's all going to be okay
but the reality is that it's the power
structure itself that is the problem
that needs to be and and I think but
both can be true at the same time right
so like I think both of those things are
true I think yes it's like power
corrupts this is you know what I mean
like and that's and that's a big part of
it um and and just like you said it's
like this whole thing this so I'm not
like one of these see this is what I
think is so stupid about the kind of
like uh um I don't know like the the
kind of not alt-right but like whatever
that whole bigger right-wing world is
and their critique of Libertarians is
basically like no no no we just got this
bad group in right now if we get them
out then we can have the government you
know run for Christians or whatever
their plan is no no this is stupid
because it is like you said it's
inherent in the structure not only
stupid democracy dangerous look the the
mix of democracy and big government look
at it obviously what what is it Inc what
is it draw out of every politician to
say the most dumb down slogan to play to
the most uninformed voter to just say
the St this is why Donald Trump did so
well because Donald Trump was like I'll
do you one better I'll talk like a
kindergartener and just say this I'll
just say say everything's terrific or
stupid and but really it's not as if any
of the others are much better than that
there was one speech that I was writing
about where he was talking about um how
you have to flush the toilet 10 to 15
times nowadays so lowf flow toilets he
was talking about how you have to run
your dishwasher like 15 times and at the
end of this uh whole rant he said
Housewives vote for me and I just love
that agree to which like so many other
politicians it would be this like that
would be implicit and Donald Trump is
smart enough to just make it a [__]
explicit call to action wives vote for
me I critiqued the toilets I he run his
own dishwasher in in but it's also like
I you know it's it's total exaggeration
also I get where he's talking about with
like the dumb environmentalist
restrictions just make everyday life a
little bit worse in so many ways and
that's kind of what a lot of the
progressive left wants I'm sorry but
like I chafe every single time I get
like a paper bag in the grocery store
versus a [__] plastic bag because
it's just a matter of like why is it
that we're there's a huge contingent
that's just trying to make everyday life
a little bit worse and Donald Trump I
think very successfully tapped into into
that yeah
100% but then so you're so you're going
to have this whole dynamic of like power
look by definition almost polit politics
is going to attract people who want to
rule over other people so that's already
that's what the magnet is there and then
of course it's re the problem it's this
mix of big government and democracy
which are very related right so you have
to appeal to a a population who by again
by definition are only a very small
percentage of them are going to know
much about politics because that's true
about everything like that's true about
anything like that's true only a small
percentage of people have expertise in
any field right so then you have that
and then because the government's so big
there is so much power being wielded
that it's inevitably completely
corrupted I mean the what is our federal
government going to spend this year I
think over6 trillion doar if you're if
you're spending $6 trillion doll
somebody is going to be like actively
lobbying to get that power but Dave so
this is uh what this is the danger that
I see in the populist strategy is that
this right-wing that you mentioned um
that it does exist the the NC cons or
whatever we want to call them that they
just want to
install their version of a virtuous
leader to impose their vision of the
world and that is what that that's their
analysis is that that we have these
these um corrupt uh degenerates running
the government and we need you know good
virtuous uh Caesars or whatever running
the government and I worry sometimes
that the populist strategy in
libertarianism
is uh trying to cultivate that and it's
strengthening it and and this is like a
pattern you see throughout history is
the Socialists wreck things and then the
right-wing you know F fascist or
whatever you uh whatever form they take
then comes in and imposes right-wing
dictatorship or whatever and that unless
you
know Malay is a kind of interesting
example because he's he's coming in uh
on on to to fix what the Socialists have
done and the peronists have done um but
he's extremely explicit about who the
enemy yeah I mean we'll see again like
by the way we'll see how he does I don't
know if he's the real deal or I'm saying
he said this stuff and he won on that so
that in itself is interesting so I
basically I think you're almost exactly
right there right like that kind of
tends to be like this pattern that's
played out over and over again which is
like and you could see this um like
where there'd be these awful uh
right-wing movements as a response to
Communism like all throughout the world
in the 20th century and look man like I
I think almost to me that's why you need
this libertarian populism even more
because that's one of the most important
components to put out this right-wing
fire because there is something really
dangerous there too like I mean I I
think about I I remember saying this on
uh Rogan's podcast a few appearances
back where I was like I almost like you
know when you'll see these like the
craziest of the woke whatever the
craziest woke thing is you know they're
just like there we we're going to
convince this three-year-old boy he's a
girl or like there's like some you know
like drag queen giving a lap dance to
like a seven-year-old or something the
lady Rabbi on TV talking about the you
know Glory of Hamas but she had like a
beard yeah like there's whatever but you
see it and it's you're almost like it's
like my first thought is like whoa
that's really insane and awful and then
like your immediate second thought is
like oh my God we're gonna live under a
right-wing dictator CU my God like what
the backlash to this is going to be and
it's usually not going to be some
right-winger who's like going to be like
well listen you have your right to be a
transgender person just maybe we
shouldn't push this on kids it's going
to be someone being like no you don't
have a right to do this and you know and
so the libertarian thing there is like
you got to kind of like try to to
harness that populist energy but in an
explicitly libertarian way talking about
that it's like no like the only answer
here and and this is kind of to me the
great libertarian Insight right cuz like
fundamentally we're kind of like a
compromise that's kind of like what
libertarianism is is it's it's almost
like no call a truce like that's it like
you don't get to impose your view on
them and they don't get to impose their
view on you but you both get to do what
you want to do right like with your own
lives but that's kind of the thing that
the the the Insight is that it's like
that's actually also better for you like
in the long run you attempting to impose
your view on other people is going to
end up in them trying to do the same
thing to you and everybody loses hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
new show just asking questions you can
watch another clip here or the full
episode here new episodes drop every
week so subscribe to reent TV's YouTube
channel to get notified when that
happens or to the just asking questions
podcast on Apple Spotify or any other
podcatcher see you next week